it's game time the UK's Tiger games
awards 2014 and it's been a good year so
do you play games honestly is going from
strength to strength in 2013 we grew by
about seven percent a year incident with
billion pounds UK gdp
hundreds in your starters and a motive
all over UK video games worth 1 billion
pounds to the UK economy the
best-selling game of last year grand
theft auto 5 sold 3.6 million units 32
million worldwide and it's made by
rockstar north based in Edinburgh there
are 800 game businesses in the UK
employing 30,000 people but the past few
months haven't all been positive
gamergate around that raged online and
it's divided the industry it began with
this game depression quest by zoe quinn
after it received favorable reviews
online the internet exploded into
allegations of favoritism based on Zoe's
supposed relationship with journalists
the developer was verbally abused and
threatened forcing her to go into hiding
gamer and blogger Anita sarkeesian
highlights the misogyny in many games
and became a target for online trolls
this episode includes game footage of
hyper sexualized female characters as
well as extremely graphic depictions of
violence against women and more an event
she was due to speak at was cancelled
after a threat was made against her life
the female developers we spoke to at the
tiger Awards was shocked by the abuse
but said it was a small minority who
didn't represent the industry as a whole
come I've seen
generally a group of people arguing on
twitter has also been wrastlin side of
things
never justifies and should be dealt with
appropriately this is the award-winning
velocity 2x made by kirsty a frenetic
blast through imagined worlds you play
as kind and your goals are pretty clear
so if game against had any upside it may
well be that women both in and outside
these pixel generated universes see
their status level up